on this episode I talk the long-term
value of email oranges and gurus you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee show everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and welcome to episode
number 35 of the askgaryvee show fun
fact about the number 35 that is the big
hurt Frank Thomas's number my favorite
non Yankee baseball player because I
collected all his rookie cards and my
friend Brandon died who runs wine
library right now made up agreement when
we were 15 that a friend Thomas was
going to be awesome because we bought
his rookie cards and he went to the Hall
of Fame that we would go that happened
this last summer as the big herd got
inducted we went up there but something
weird happened we realized there was a
90-mile garage sale going on in the
general area and we skipped the Hall of
Fame and we went to the 90 mile garage
sale
that's called adjusting Madison asks as
an email marketer I say email is not
dead do you think email will be more or
less relevant in three to five years
Madison great question three to five
years it's always hard to predict that
way out but I'll get to that part and
we're actually answering this question I
just want to give a huge shout out to
the vaynernation
for supporting this show I'm uh I'm
really enjoying it I was super bummed
about Friday night so I apologize I
think I tweeted that I was going to have
it and let some people down I hate
letting people down email is definitely
not dead I would say that email right
now I like marketing in the year that we
live in so I would say right now that
email is a very killer app now our open
rates at ninety percent like I had in
1997 absolutely not but is it an own
channel that you control and don't have
to be at the mercy of all these other
platforms that you can market to your
people for sure I think we can't be
naive to the fact that Google made
changes with Gmail about a year ago
feels like now or within the year where
we went to a promotions tab I see
stunwin shaking his head Steve were you
affected by the promotions tab were you
part of any email lists that you noticed
went there oh yeah absolutely now here's
the here's the punch line question show
me punch line question here's the punch
line question
do you feel that some of those that got
switched to the promotion tabs you've
actually fallen off because they don't
go to your native infeed and you either
unsubscribed or you just don't pay
attention to anymore totally gone yep
probably five or six events that's my
concern
so what's happening is do I think email
will matter three to five years for sure
I think it's in play it's a channel it's
not going anywhere do I think it's dead
absolutely not do I think it'll be more
or less valuable as a marketing engine I
will go with less valuable in three to
five years it will still be very
valuable because it's one of the best
channels but it will be less valuable
that whole marketers ruin everything
line that I use a lot that's what this
is all about platforms come along they
have value and then we mark it against
them and then consumers kind of push off
its cops-and-robbers
its cat mouse over and over and over
again and we're living in a process now
that we're into the second decade of
email being ruined by marketers Troy
asks I work in two different spaces how
do I use social media platforms so that
I'm not confusing my audience Troy this
is a very simple question you adjust the
platform at hand so we're going very
detailed on this show for Twitter the
way you don't confuse them if you're
talking about two different things
a la business and wine talk is you
create two different channels and you
have an at Wine Library account and you
have an at Gary Vaynerchuk account Gary
Vee and that's what I did or you just
become so branded in both that you feel
comfortable being kind of a Renaissance
man or woman and you can go that route
but you have to react to the platforms
so on Twitter you just create two
different accounts and you promote
through them on Facebook though the
targeting capabilities allows you to
just be yourself and talk to people that
act you can plan to people that are 25
to 45 that are into wine and you put out
a wine content and they'll like that and
you know 22 to 27 that are into podcasts
and you do that and then they want you
to talk about that thing so Facebook
gives you the flexibility to target you
know Twitter does not and so you've got
to adjust YouTube channel do you have
two channels you have one is something
we've talked about because we want to
chop up every answer into a question
right let's link up the first one we put
up right the tennis thing
yeah and so uh you know you're the real
answer to this question phrase is you've
got adjust to the platform's capability
to drive home the fragmentation or the
one-channel process so you go plot place
by place Pinterest you can create a
board right you can have an account you
can create different boards and then
certain boards you put out content about
whatever the hell you're doing and
whatever you're doing that's different
so you tumblr you can create a bunch of
different kind of blog on tumblr comm so
that gives you flexibility so giving you
very detailed answer to here's my friend
it's it's a not super hard you have
that's right strategy per the platform
based on the flexibility of that
platform to deliver the story Michael
asks how do you define hustle
Michael this is funny because show his
face cuz I could see him grinning this
was the first query 35 in 5 this is the
first question 150 questions that I can
like see from the corner of my eye
literally said how do you define hustle
is he good see this up this is because
you know I mean this is a challenging
question so first of all it's different
for everybody right but what I would say
hustle is to me
is that when you have passion around
something that you were squeezing every
last bit of the juice out of the orange
right to me Hustle is maximizing the
energy you're putting into somebody I'm
blown away by people saying that they're
hustling and they want to achieve these
great things and then their actions
don't match it's like saying you really
want to lose weight while eating a Big
Mac right so to me Hustle would be
putting all your effort into achieving
the goal at hand and for me that means
making every minute count hiring a
full-time assistant who's ever I mean
Friday night didn't happen because I was
hustling like every minute like if I
miss my 15 minutes to tape the show I've
missed my 15 minutes because there's so
much hustle my day there's no you know
there's no like hey I there's no hanging
out there's no like time we're like if I
get to do like one joke with you guys as
I'm walking in between meetings we like
to find out to be like a rare
acquaintance situation like like
occurrence not acquaintances uh Hustle
is putting it all on the line Hustle is
waking up one day the day before you die
and realizing you gave
you're all into the parenting of your
children the building of your businesses
the four lamp three that you wanted to
do whatever you define it's just you
know all-in emotionally and executional
II in theory and strategy and an
execution hey Bridget Williger from you
too can be a guru and hashtag guru
minute videos I finally have a question
for Gary Vina vaynernation for
askgaryvee show one of my um people
asked me out of curiosity what does it
what do you really get from having
10,000 followers so I'm deferring to you
and your wisdom I remember you too could
be a guru that was that was a nice voice
at the end there some real talent in the
vaynernation by the way there will be no
show on on Thursday because AJ and I are
going to Cleveland to see LeBrons first
game back in Cleveland against my New
York Knicks and so excited about that
hence a little public service
announcement also if you've not been
paying attention I've been writing my
ass off on garyvaynerchuk.com so check
that out please click out I love in the
comments as an effect in the comments
question of the day what do you think of
the garyvaynerchuk.com website pros cons
your thoughts your two cents your three
cents if you want to roll that way
to answer this question you too can be a
guru by the way I want to I want to
address that real quick we've kind of
addressed that recently like you can be
a guru if you actually got guru skills
you can't just say you're a guru that's
number one and then take answer the
question that is the wrong question what
is 10,000 fans get you nothing or
everything I don't know if you have
10,000 fans who 9,000 of which by every
by 48 copies of your book when you put
it out on Twitter well then that sounds
really valuable if you've got 10,000
fans because you bought them on some
weird eBay auction because you want to
act cool amongst your friends and when
you post something nobody gives a rat's
ass I would say that's less valuable and
so the question my friends is always the
wrong thing but like this is what
everybody gets confused about I could
care less about the top line awareness
though it matters
right like what are like 14 million
people watching this video mean means I
got more at-bats of people to get into
my content into my world find value and
me thus creating the beginning of a
relationship which then may lead to
something but life is long it's a long
trail all you need is one follower of
that 10,000 really changed the course of
your business or personal life right and
so that's the wrong question
the right question is what are you
trying to achieve see my friends I'm a
reverse engineer let me say it again
because if you haven't figured it out in
the seven years that you followed me I'm
gonna say one more time as a matter of
fact second show Zach's face because I'm
gonna tell him something right to his
face Zach I need a t-shirt that says I'm
a reverse engineer and as you know I
never scrutinized the creative and I'm
always like great this one I'm gonna
care about because I want to wear it
every goddamn day because that's who I
am I'm a reverse engineer whether I need
10,000 followers or I need to what every
decision is predicated on what am I
trying to achieve both long-term and
short-term and that's the key my friends
one of the things you have to do is you
have to balance both your short-term
goals and your long-term goals so I want
to buy the Jets and so a lot of things
that I do I leave tons of money on the
table because I think it would hurt my
brand or my perception or my
opportunities or I don't feel good about
it I feel like I could burn a bridge a
bridge I may need to buy the Jets same
token I need to build a vaynermedia to
be a huge company so that could afford
amazing employees like this to scale
content like this so it's all strategy
but I'm always thinking about why why
why why why why it all has to be reverse
engineered so why do you need 10,000
fans maybe in 2007 you needed 10,000
fans or the value was you were one of
the only people with 10,000 fans and
everybody thought you were cool
even people followed me just cuz I had a
lot of followers back in 2006 and 7 and
8 and that gave me leverage they then
paid attention to be lucky for me I
don't even know why I'm doing air quotes
right now because that's how fired up I
am but lucky for me I had something good
to say whether it was about wine and
that's a basketball weather is about
giving get me some wine so I'm gonna
give me a bottle of wine is we have wine
here when there was about wine whether
it's about business I don't know why
this represents business yes get through
hurry well there's about wine there's
about business and
Oh 10,000 fans or anything else you do
why do I need a medium account why do I
need a million fans on Facebook why
should I be marketing on snapchat it's
all strategy for me I mark it on
snapchat because I want to learn the
platform because I want to always be
ahead because I want to earn the right
for you to spend these 15 minutes with
me and the only reason you're spending
these 15 minutes with me and yes I'm
very attractive and yes a massively
charismatic but it's because I'm
providing you value I'm saving you time
to spend the hundreds of hours that I
and my organization spend to give you
the punch lines of what you need to know
to navigate through a 2015 marketing
world and that's it and it's that simple
so the values of stupid question the
right question is what are you trying to
accomplish and is Twitter the platform
that can help you accomplish it if it is
now you start understanding what the
value would be my friends that one more
Walton I'll take it Amy asks a professor
once said to me it's better to be a big
fish in a small pond do you agree
Amy this set you know I'm gonna be very
upfront on this question this is a good
way to bang out the show that sounds
like a loser professor to me
it's small-time thinking I don't
subscribe to it there's a lot of
practicality in it right there's it's a
lot easier to be the most successful
businessman in st. Louis Missouri than
it is to be in the world right so I
understand the thesis but honestly that
to me is very conservative not in my DNA
thinking that could be great advice for
a lot of people who are delirious and
think they're better than they are
though I love to drive through
self-esteem and optimism and I think
early in your life you should absolutely
shoot for the highest stars that you can
I think as life moves on and time moves
on you need to become more practical
you've got bills and kids and all those
kind of things but to start off one's
career in the first 20 years call to
your 40 to be in that thinking I think
that limits there being so many people
who've hedged and settled in their lives
and honestly I'm not the kind of
character that's going to play in that
kind of sphere I'm going in a different
direction
it's what
natural to me but it's also because I
think I could be the biggest and the
baddest in any game I play it's just how
I'm wired I think this comes down to
it's probably very good advice to some
and it's probably atrocious advice to
others and this is why I continue say if
I can inject anything into anybody it
would be self awareness because it would
help you answer this question because
for a lot of people it's probably really
solid advice for me and for many of you
watching this it's crap advice alright
now I can wrap up the show my friends
this time thank you so much for watching
the show
you've got your question of the day
thank you for listening watching jamming
interacting the banter from the last
episode was phenomenal I miss all of you
and I can't wait to tape tomorrow's show
which is going to be early and I'm
excited and so we'll have that up early
tomorrow in the scheme of things early
afternoon versus late afternoon
d-roc no pressure you keep asking
questions I will keep answering them
none of that part oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe